our next guest has been the host of so
you think you can dance for over
a decade i just i love that show so much
um and she's now the author of a
children's book
it's called the joy in you i read it
last night to my daughters
and we're also having that book reviewed
by none other than our own news
correspondent
jonah larson so please welcome kat
deeley and jonah larson i
can't tell you how excited i am i
watched the review that jonah did
um with henry winkler the other day and
i've got to say
i quit so i'm really excited
i just want to say that i i read
my book your book excuse me to my
daughters last night
and um i can't wait to hear jonah's
reviews
as well and kat i'm just such a huge fan
of yours by the way
um i'm really excited that you're on the
show right now and i will hand it over
to my
co-pilot jonah take it away with your
review
hi drew hi cat let's start by
saying look at these turkey coasters i
made for craft week
[Music]
oh they're amazing those are so awesome
jonah
if you have an extra one will you please
send it so i can put it on the desk here
cert certainly but let's get in to the
joy in you
i really just loved the book let's start
off with the title
the joy in you i'm so amazed
how those few words imply that there's
joy
inherently inside of us and we just need
to find it
and express it and be grateful for it
next up the feeling as soon as you open
the book is joy and happiness
the illustrator must have used a happy
brush because it's so
bright and vibrant it just brings me joy
and finally the closing picture with a
mother koala cradling her baby
the message that that sends is so
meaningful from one picture
about whether it's your mom your dad
your siblings a friend
there's always someone there for you to
help push you
because you never know how far you can
go unless you try
jonah that is an absolutely beautiful
review and cat what are you thinking of
the review
i don't know if i can talk so
oh my goodness that that was the
loveliest review i could have possibly
hoped for
um it's it's slightly better than my
little boys review my little book
my little boy's review went along the
lines well i can't do anything because
what i really want to do is take a
koala home from the zoo i can't do that
and i was like no you can't do that milo
but you could go to school and you could
study
and you could study something called
biology and then you could become a
zoologist and then maybe
you could go and work at a zoo and and
look after every koala or even travel to
the other side of the world and go and
work in a koala sanctuary
with koalas who don't i mean now he's
thinking all this through drew it was
like seven o'clock at night and i'm
exhausted and in my pajamas and i don't
know where he came from but he did
and jonah that was such a lovely review
thank you so much you absolutely 100
got exactly where i was going with this
book
um and it's the the fact that you can be
anything that you want to be it doesn't
matter where you come from
or what your background is if you find
something that you
love and you work really hard at it you
can be
anything you want to be and i think as
moms and dads that's what we want for
our children we want them to be happy
and we want them to be kind and as far
as i can see you're a glowing example of
that
he really is i knew i was going wrong no
and i have to say
as a mother reading it to my daughters
these are the exact
you know incentives that we want to
instill in our children i thought it was
just beautiful
and i thank you cat for coming on the
show
and as always jonah you just give the
most soulful
you know amazing reviews
and i thank you both so much the joy in
you
is available now
[Music]